02 / AK moins un new york nvidia
actuellement alutia actuellement il dit ou
cool voiture zone cervicale supprime les névroses en
fait Moran septembre do men saison
de novo repa Moyes westmill personne prend au
piège chasser une nouvelle année ciragan
représenter une partie sur le terrain de jeu
dépression le concevoir à la maison une famille donc
significativement refuge deuxième lire des livres
sur les sodas une famille un concave une
injustice de corrosion derrière quoi que ce soit ouais
j'avais 17 ans j'avais une arme de poing que
je transportais et c'était tu
sais un frère pour la protection je ne
volais personne ou ne faisais rien  mal
et fondamentalement ma mère a trouvé mon arme de poing
dans ma chambre un jour et elle m'a donné le
choix tu sais euh et elle m'a donné une
église parce qu'encore une fois étant la mère
d'un jeune homme noir en Amérique tu as
certaines peurs tu n'as pas toi  toi tu as
peur que ton fils se
promène avec l'arme de poing tu sais
que ces flics vont le tuer tu sais
qu'il y a certaines ambiances où il
peut aller et je vais provoquer  lui de faire
quelque chose qui détruit sa propre
vie J'ai choisi de quitter la maison
parce qu'en tant qu'homme j'avais commencé à développer
mes propres idéaux J'ai commencé à développer mon
propre état d'esprit et j'ai réalisé que nos
parents ne peuvent pas nous sauver vous savez tout mon
maman peut faire s'il m'arrive quelque chose, c'est
pleurer sur ma tombe, vous savez, en tant que jeune
homme, j'ai dû développer mon propre niveau d'
indépendance et j'ai à Venise ce
combat qui s'est terminé dans cet abri, vous savez
comme à New Yorker j'ai  vu que l'
itinérance est une institution financière,
c'est une institution économique dans laquelle
les représentants du gouvernement gagnent de l'argent, vous savez
si vous regardez les refuges pour sans-abri,
ils reçoivent certaines subventions certaines
portions d'argent par an qui les
maintiennent ouverts, donc cela fait partie de l'
agenda pour  garder les gens sans abri, cela fait partie
de l'agenda pour garder les gens dans la
rue et ce faisant, ils sont capables de
dire hé écoutez, vous connaissez 500, vous
connaissez un millier de personnes à New York
qui ont besoin que vous connaissiez un endroit où rester et
alors ils donnent de l'argent pour ouvrir
ces institutions le problème c'est que
j'ai moi-même été sans abri c'est qu'ils n'aident pas
nécessairement les gens à se
relever ce qu'ils font c'est qu'ils
vous institutionnalisent en quelque sorte ils vous aident à
construire un état d'esprit d'être sans abri  ils
vous aident à dépendre du système et
c'est ce que Trump dit, vous savez et
c'est pourquoi, même si je les
déteste, Trump a certains points,
vous savez que Trump dit bien, vous savez que nous
voulons mettre fin aux sans-abri, vous voulez amener les
gens  dans les emplois, nous voulons arrêter ces
programmes qui aident réellement les gens ou
leur permettent de maintenir un statut de
sans-abrisme J'aimerais entendre ces
problèmes être davantage abordés
dans la politique américaine en général, cela
ne devrait pas être une
campagne présidentielle, cela devrait  être et
faire campagne pour mettre fin à ce genre de
choses, il devrait s'agir d'une campagne continue
pour mettre fin à l'itinérance et pour
connaître le salaire minimum limité que les
gens sont payés et ce que je réalise
est que si ces problèmes ne se posent que là-bas dans
la campagne, cela signifie qu'ils ne se poseront pas
après la campagne, ce que vous
réalisez, c'est qu'il n'y a rien, aucune
déclaration réelle n'est faite, il n'y a aucune
preuve réelle que les choses vont
changer et donc ce que des individus comme
moi font comme  comme Javier faisant,
nous voulons en avoir assez pour rien quand
vous manquiez d'itinérance J'ai vu
Javier donner des emplois à des gens qui sont mes
amis qui sont au bord de l'
itinérance, ces
propriétaires d'entreprise indépendants comme lui et moi qui
s'attaquent vraiment à l'itinérance en donnant à
nos amis  et ceux qui nous tiennent à cœur l'
opportunité de venir vivre l'art d'
être vraiment